no one wants to see you at home like
topless waving down the smoke alarm hey
some people might want to see that
all right everyone welcome to Next Level
kitchen where we're taking your cooking
skills to the next level by teaching you
the skills and techniques to make some
Next Level dishes and today we're going
to show you how to take a dish that many
of you are familiar with and take it to
the next level fried rice oh my gosh
fried rice a favorite in my house a
staple in so many cultures in Asia and
around the world and we're going to show
you how to do it in a walk or a pan and
Aisha hopefully Uncle Roger will approve
of these dishes but first let's talk
about the actual how we cook it a wok a
pan how do you like to do it
um you know think it depends on the type
of fried rice right there's Thai fried
rice Chinese style fried rice I'm gonna
kind of do my Cali Korean Vibe of a
fried rice so I see you're using a wok
I'm actually going to use just a
standard sort of larger saute pan the
almighty hex clad oh I like it almost
like a non-stick too so like that's good
people think you have to cook in a wok
you don't have to cook in a wok
um but I do have one from our beloved
basement level kitchen the blazeman look
at this thing it's all wobbly I don't
know where we found it but I'm gonna try
and walk it up today all right so I'm
gonna get into my dish over here I'm
doing a prawn fried rice right uh prawn
fried rice so real quick I have these
beautiful whole head-on prawns I like to
just sort of rip off their legs it's
kind of barbaric perhaps but that's why
I like to just peel it to get the tail
off of these peel them pretty easy again
these are fresh right so they're
sticking a little bit to their body but
really easy if you get a shell on shrimp
or prawns very easy to pull the shell
off of them and then you could use this
to flavor or sauce or something down the
line exactly but what I'm left with this
I got my my prawn bodies over here I'm
going to chop those up here's my tip
about cooking in a wok uh is that you
just got to get all your mise and place
done and ready to cook because it all
happens sort of at the end what are you
making yeah so I'm gonna make a uh sort
of Korean inspired fried rice this is
for me I think fried rice is an
opportunity to use potentially leftover
ingredients in your fridge right I have
some beautiful sausage I have some
kimchi that you know I may use for a
soup uh you know it's over fermented so
I'm actually going to use it in the
fried rice today you're going to use
some garlic a little ginger I have some
eggs kimchi fried rice yes next level
for you to taste it there it is so I've
actually had some leftover rice that's
really key ingredient to fried rice is
using day old rice right so this rice is
nice and granular it's not stuck
together it's not hot so it's going to
be perfect for my fried rice okay I'm
over here and I'm getting again all of
my ingredients together because
especially when you are cooking in a wok
or you're making fried rice it happens
so quick at the end that you don't have
time to run to the fridge to grab your
your Ginger your garlic your carrots or
whatever it is so I just shredded some
carrots I think it's easier that way
using some technology I smashed some
garlic over here and then I just want to
sort of rough chop it just get in there
chop up some garlic look at the camera
while you're doing it
don't look at the camera while you're
doing it because you probably don't have
a camera in your house right now you're
sure maybe you do maybe you're making a
tick tock but man I think in this day
and age most people have some pretty
extensive setups in their home awesome
another tip I have over here it looks
like you're using ginger as well I like
to barely I don't even I barely peel the
ginger I just peel around the sides and
then I just take a grater you can shop
this but I feel like it's a little easy
for the ginger to just use a grater and
then when I'm done that's all I need
about equal parts ginger and garlic I
can just put it back in the fridge wrap
it in a wet towel and this is how I
don't use all the ginger exposed that
flesh to the elements in your fridge so
you got chilies over there I do have
chilies I love a spicy dish
um I also actually love that you said to
save the ginger like that because you
can actually germinate that ginger in
your fridge and make a little new Ginger
Tree are you germinating Ginger we make
a ginger a new tree you can like Sprout
it oh my gosh it's a root
um so super sustainable tip uh so yeah I
had I do have some uh Fresno chili here
it's one of my favorite California
chilies I also have some pork sausage I
love the texture that comes off of this
style of sausage and what I'm gonna do I
think you know when you're dicing
ingredients right and how you are
breaking these ingredients down it's
really important to think about mouth
feel right you don't want big chunks of
ingredients and small grains of rice
right uh you know that would lend to a
different style of fried rice and for me
I want everything to sort of be around
the same size so I'm going to what we'd
call a small dice I love that tip I love
that too ingredient all right so I got
some chilies over here I'm not copying
you but I have I have some carrots I
have some garlic ginger and scallions
pretty much I feel like like kind of the
Trinity is garlic ginger scallions or
onion ginger and garlic right and uh
totally if you don't have scallions use
an onion use a shallot whatever you have
and
by the way you said uh germ you're
germinating Ginger and you're using
alliums I suck up a chef or something
your next level by the way we're gonna
do the fast forward where that Ginger
Tree Grows All right I got my prawns I'm
gonna chop up right so you're are you
almost ready to jump in the pan over
there uh yeah so what I like to do I
mean before I start cooking I think you
know you noted it it's really important
to have all of your ingredients ready
although sauteing is really just the
part that and the element that brings
these ingredients together right so I
have my saute pan preheating I'm going
to say it's about a medium-high heat all
right I also love the fact that most
fried rice dishes you'll have a little
bit of scrambled egg in there yes you
don't need it but for me it's a little
extra protein if you're trying to stay
healthy right my kids by the way one of
my kids doesn't like eggs at all wow so
like I have to sneak it into the meal by
like just making it in fried rice she
doesn't realize that there's she does
now wait does she she realize it now she
realizes it now because I'm saying it
I'm gonna just actually fry my egg and
place it on top so I get that runny yolk
that kind of hugs all of those rice
grains so I get a little bit of that
crispy egg on the outside with the
creamy yolk going to be really delicious
I love that and uh so here's a key to me
I do have this Wok that I'm hoping is
seasoned it's from the basement I have a
little bit of sesame oil I'm gonna put
in here a fair
little right because I really I'm really
hoping nothing's
spanned totally and you want us to be
really really hot that's the key to I
think good while cooking and you can see
right now coming off of this you can see
the smoke that means that the pan is
ready and I'm going to start my cooking
are you going to start your cooking love
it kind of that jumping hot out yes yes
jumping which is the word saute by the
way which means jump is what saute means
so we want this to jump in the pan so
I'm going to start uh with a little bit
of my carrots in here
I'm gonna start cooking there and here's
the great thing about the wok and I can
see because I have it hot nothing's
sticking and now I'm just gonna add all
the other ingredients based on how long
they're going to cook I'm going to put
my prawns in there I'm going to add all
of my aromatics the chilies the garlic
the ginger and then this is where it
gets fun right like this is where it
gets fun nothing's sticking that's
because the pan was hot and you can
smell the ginger in the garlic
am I getting too excited about this and
you're doing the same exactly again yeah
layering the in the aromatics right
controlling the heat for me I really
want to drive the flavors out of these
chilies and the Beautiful sweetness
coming off of the sausage I'm going to
hit it with a little bit of fresh garlic
and I don't want my pan too hot because
the aromatics can tend to burn but I
definitely want them to caramelize and
and cook and showcase their amazing
flavors so I'll hit it with some ginger
as well as garlic
and again it makes for super easy
cleanup when you can go directly
straight into that pan get a little
bicep workout and uh the aromatics are
absolutely stunning on both of these
both of these are going well I'm also
going to add a little bit of peas tip on
peas these are frozen peas straight from
my freezer and I just let them defrost
because they're just about cooked love
it and I don't want to overcook them if
you're going to add a pea it's going to
cook really really quickly so just a
little bit of peas in there love it love
it love it love it and then again
jumping in the pan and you get the
flavor if you are cooking in a wok it's
called the walk a you get the flavor of
sort of the tin absolutely the iron of
the pan going all those ancestors love
that yeah so I've started to build this
sort of first initial layer of my fried
rice and again you know I use the term
aromatics and that comes in a few
different forms right this is that first
base layer right this is the foundation
of the rice that je ne sais quoi when
you say something you're like why is it
so delicious it's because there was time
spent in developing the flavor of the
aromatic right so garlic ginger chilies
that beautiful pork fat starting to
render out and now
what I want to do is I want to push all
of my aromatics to one side of the pan
and really that's going to allow so you
have this beautiful golden color coming
off that's from the capsaicin in the
chilies right color is always flavor say
some we're going to need like to have
someone like explain all of these words
the the spice that's in chilies right
100 yeah and also the color and the uh
and the Beautiful aromatics and aroma so
now I'm going to go in with my rice and
I want to allow that to caramelize a
little bit I one thing for me about
fried rice is I love the texture right a
little bit of caramelized bits a little
bit of crispiness it's fried rice yeah
it has to be fried it has to be 100 I
love that you're keeping the aromatics
on the side over there exactly kind of
dual cooking you're getting ready to do
the toss what you got going I have I
made a little well in the wok again I'm
trying to get the same thing naisha's
doing a little bit of the texture the
actual rice frying so I have a well in
my Wok now and here's some of the eggs
and I'm just going to take that that
little scrambled egg mixture go right
into the middle this is my favorite part
right here you know what I'm I'm going
to add a little bit of salt because I'm
going to add soy but Soy and salts are a
little different absolutely that's what
I always tell our chefs because you can
you not absolutely taste it when there's
not seasoning in every single layer of
the dish right you can and again soy is
salty but they're totally different
things 100 percent
and there it is a little scrambled eggs
now
getting ready to toss this around
breaking up those eggs
you got the sausage in there too yeah so
that pork fat is starting to render out
the pork is in sausage is becoming
crispy and and chewy almost and the
chilies have developed they're they're
at maximum capacity of flavor right now
Garlic's caramelizing Ginger is just
becoming so happy and lovely in this pan
now the rice is doing its thing right
dual uh cooking here in one pan and it's
starting to take on those flavors slowly
right this is when you can start to
multitask at this stage you know you're
pouring your little glass of wine or
you're calling a friend and that is
that's the ultimate multitasking 100
right so for me I mean I just I feel
like fried rice if you're not ordering
takeout it's an easy weeknight dinner
right after work
um and a great way to use up ingredients
so at this stage once that Rice starts
to caramelize I hear these beautiful
popping sounds that's telling me that
it's starting to become golden brown and
delicious on the opposite end of this
rice and now I just want to go in
and start to build on the Umami and go
in with a second layer or second
installment of flavor right we have that
first layer of aromatics and again the
soy as Richard has in his is going to
help caramelize my rice right so I want
to do a little bit of a drizzle not too
much
right a little bit of soy a little bit
of fish sauce right and that's going to
play with the natural Umami and the soy
and also the Kim you got some big
flavors you got fish sauce right again
which is like you're not tasting fish
you're just getting that genese Hua that
you were saying that I don't know what
that is that makes food delicious it's
called Umami absolutely in a different
way to add salt I'm just gonna add a
touch of sesame oil right I'm gonna keep
that flavor of the Sesame and again just
notice I haven't really moved the pan
much I want that caramelization I want
those notes to hit a little bit of chew
it is a little bit of crispiness and a
little bit of freshness by adding
scallions at the very end so I'm going
to slice some scallions I'm going to get
fancy and cut them on a bias you can cut
them however you'd like all right how
you finishing up over there yeah so I'm
just gonna drop my egg straight into
this pan and that's going to fry up and
while I plate my fried rice that's going
to be cooking simultaneously I think uh
it's really important to sort of
multitask when cooking you're going to
leave the egg like nice and beautiful
like that I am going to leave the egg
nice and beautiful like that so what I'm
going to do now is allow this rice to
caramelize on the opposite end and then
I'll just start to fold in a touch of
this kimchi juice and the kimchi itself
and just start to fold these flavors
together right and I'm thinking about
balance
thinking about balance
so folding in
there it is
[Music]
that's that okay that little bit of the
Char that you're getting from some of
the ingredients from the pan itself
so you know we always say it color is
flavor
there it is I'm really I was impossible
with that the egg is looking so luscious
right now oh so luscious so I add in a
little bit of scallion
fresh scallion I'm ready to Plate over
here love that can't wait to taste it
Richard okay so there we go plating a
little bit over here you can say I got
all of that you know I can see the
individual kernels of rice which is what
I'm looking for I have some more of
those scallions I like the flavor of the
bulbiness of the scallions I'm going to
add a little bit on there and then
because I do like it spicy even though I
had some chilies in the dish I'm just
gonna add a little bit of chili oil
right on top or you can do just a little
dish on the side because I do like it
spicy and obviously so do you oh I love
spicy
touch more soy
and we're ready to Plate fantastic if
this is a dish I make a lot actually I
love to use over ripe kimchi in
applications like this because generally
it's something that you eat uh straight
away but
uh the softer more fermented kimchi
lends itself really great to things like
this I love the fact that you got those
little bits of the sausage in there you
got all these deep fermented flavors yes
and presentation wise you're taking it
to the next level leaving that egg and
that yolk that's going to be able to
gush all over that oh tell me about it
okay so
yes you know as you've made such a more
traditional if you will fried rice
um
you know with that scrambled egg so
beautiful I've actually chosen to uh
keep the egg on top
so I get a little bit of that creaminess
from the yolk and what I will do here
is more but wait there's one more
wait for it there it is oh my gosh my
truck Naisha Arrington taking it to the
next level let's see bottom level maybe
top level two delicious dishes I don't
know Uncle Roger
what do you think
hmm not bad not bad both of you Uncle
Roger have to say I prefer niece Naisha
fire rice because she's using all of
Uncle Roger's favorite ingredient the
kimchi the sesame oil the fish sauce so
much Umami nephew Richard fire rice not
bad also but little too basic and don't
put peas in your Fried Rice High yeah
you want vegetable you go eat salad only
green in fried rice should be scallion
but amazing job both of you Uncle Roger
approved for you
[Music]